When I become a high school student, I want to have a normal youth,
make normal friends, and fall in love. Up
until now, people around me were afraid of my home, so I
had a hard time making friends, but from now on, things will be different. Are you
okay? I'm all
alone.  I was worried about this, so I
decided to go to school with him. What are you doing? An old
Yakuza guy is cosplaying as a high school student. Is this the
new Shinogi? Falling in
love is too early for Isakusa.
[Music]
Falling in love is ordinary and
happy.  You wo
n't have a bright future even if you have unrequited love for a yakuza That's why the young
lady and the guard dog
[Music]